bonsoir a tous un preuve par trois
spéciales dans cet entre deux tours des
élections régionales jamais en effet ce
scrutin qui doit redessiner la carte de
la france n'aura pris une telle
importance non pas en raison du nombre
réduit à l'avenir de région mais bien
sûr avec la percée historique dimanche
dernier du front national il s'agit
selon les mots répétés par manuel valls
aujourd'hui de défendre la république
nous avons donc trois invités pour
débattre de cette question ce soir avec
nous perrine exactement michel avec nous
sur ce plateau philippe dallier sénateur
les républicains de seine-saint-denis
souvent soit merci d'être avec nous
gilbert collard député front national du
vaucluse non non non non non non non du
d'or du gard pardon du niveau que je
suis depuis la 2e circonscription du
gard mille excuses et jean pierre sueur
sénateur socialiste du loiret à l'or
noir
nous allons garder les trois questions
qui rythment comme chaque semaine cette
émission péril un oui trois parties et
la première partie avec cette question
qui va s'afficher sur vos écrans le
front national peut-il être contrés dans
les régions où il est arrivé en tête
dimanche soir
deuxième question comment en est on
arrivé là
et vite troisième question exactement
troisième partie de cette émission
spéciale l'émergence de trois blocs du
tripartisme finalement annonce-t-elle
demain une recomposition politique
première question donc le front national
peut-il être contré la question porte
bien sûr sur la mobilisation des
abstentionnistes pied également sur les
reports de voix notamment une au sein
d'une gauche qui est qu'ils étaient bien
fracturé et hier et qui aujourd'hui se
rassemblent se rabibochent à la grande
inconnue également bien sûr la portée du
rempart républicain dans trois régions
où le front national est arrivé
largement en tête philippe dallier le
front national peut-il être contrée seul
en vo écoutez je l'espère ont dit oui
dimanche soir au 20h
pour constater effectivement quelle
aurait été la réaction des français
après ce qui a été un premier tour
difficile pour nous maintenant moi je
pense effectivement qu'il y aura une
mobilisation pour le second tour et
qu'on verra venir des électeurs qui ne
se sont pas déplacés on verra il est
certain également que des électeurs
s'étant déplacé au premier tour et ne
retrouvons pas les candidats pour
lesquels ils avaient voté n'iront
peut-être pas voter maintenant je pense
que lui a quand même un grand risque que
le front national en porte un certain
nombre de régions et qu'il va falloir un
véritable sursaut en notre faveur
notamment pour effectivement éviter que
3,4 région tombe dans l'escarcelle du
fonds n'a sur saulx également donc des
électeurs de gauche dans trois régions
jean pierre sueur
est ce que vous seriez prêt dimanche
prochain à voter sans état d'âme pour
christian estrosi saviez bertrand ou
encore philippe richert absolument parce
que je pense que c'est la dignité du
parti socialiste que d'avoir fait à cet
égard un choix très clair mais je veux
répondre à votre première question en
vous disant que bien sûr je pense que le
front national peut être doit être battu
je parlerai de ma région je la connais
centre val de loire
voyez vous il reste trois candidats deux
peuvent gagner le front national qui a
fait 30 % les socialistes avec françois
bonneau notre président sortant est tout
à l'heure vous savez dit un mot qui m'a
un peu fait réagir vous avez dit
rabibocher mais voyez-vous les les
représentants de la gauche dans notre
région gère ensemble la région depuis
longtemps et ça se passe bien dans de
très bonnes conditions et par conséquent
le rassemblement autour du président
s'est fait très bien et aujourd'hui mais
c'est le cas dans la région centre val
de loire
aujourd'hui les champs pour le choix
entre le front national avec tout ce que
ça représente au l'union derrière
françois bonneau
gilbert collard des la femme que je suis
est très honoré d'être avec vous et ému
ou le tollé riez je voudrais faire deux
observations qui vous concerne
si vous le permettez la première c'est
un débat entre vos trois noms mais
visiblement vous d'y échapper
parce que je considère que vous n'êtes
pas des mécaniques et que ce que vous
dites vous engage et que le respect
qu'on vous doit c'est de ne pas aller
dire ce qu'on pense
quand vous n'êtes plus là vous parlez de
sursaut républicain
vous parlez de remparts républicain mais
vous pensez vous pensez vraiment
monsieur qu' il faut un sursaut parce
qu'on est un danger gg c'était le
premier ministre qui aujourd'hui encore
à l'assemblée nationale a dit que
c'était là notre république qui était en
jeu alors vous devez répondre
ouvrez vous pour répondre au premier
ministre il a dit non non j'ai bien
écouté ce que vous avez dit je note au
fur et à mesure j'étais à l'assemblée
j'ai entendu du rêve ça m'a fait éclater
de rire il a dit il faut défendre la
république moi je préférerais qu'ils
nous défendre contre des ch contre le
chômage contre la pauvreté m'enfin bon
chacun ses objectifs
je crois franchement moi ça ne me touche
même plus voyez vous parce que j'ai pas
de preuve à faire
bon mais je pense que c'est insulter
franchement directement tous les braves
gens qui vont tourner où qu'ils
respectent la république
moi je suis député de la nation je
demande à être respecté à ce titre même
par le premier ministre la république je
la défends à l'assemblée je me bats avec
les armes de la démocratie et je trouve
vraiment et une seconde j'aurai terminé
mais après si vous voulez je ne parlerai
plus non je ne sais si on appelle cela
je veux crever les abcès bon donc je
voulais défendre la république alors que
en paca monsieur estrosi a été qualifié
par les socialistes de droite extrême et
que à l'intérieur même des socialistes
il y à une bronca d'élus qui disent on
aurait dû se maintenir dans le grand est
est ce que le candidat qui a déposé sa
liste est un facho ancien sénateur
ministre de lionel jospin pas dire il
faut arrêter à un moment donné on peut
débattre on peut discuter on peut avoir
tort
on peut avoir tort ou à raison il
inverse
c'est le renversement du pour et du
contre mais vouloir nous faire gober à
la chose pareil c'est pas possible
peut-on évoquer donc là les valeurs et
la défense de la république messieurs je
pense que le parti que le front national
est un parti qui est antirépublicain qui
ne partagent pas les valeurs de la
réplique m ceci dit je vais vous dire la
préférence nationale
vous n'arrêtez pas de stigmatiser les
gens qui ont une autre couleur de peau
une autre au niveau des salines
différemment dans un aréna côté monsieur
et vous avez adoré cette tournure si
vous voulez vous battre tous les deux
vous avez fallait et patrick avec elle
bien écouter fait de la discrimination
et bien écoutez je vous dis que ce que
dit constamment le front national est
pas vrai vous êtes année pleine la rn2
lobont si vous le voulez bien je
voudrais vous dire ce que je pense je me
souviens vous dis je vais vous dire et
ce pour chacun en temps j'ai ouïe dire
ce que je pense je pense que vous êtes
frappés et jeudi avec vivement de
courtoisie mais c'est un diagnostic
d'arriération mentale mais bon parce que
si vous pensez vous vous aussi alors là
c'est peut-être moi laissez moi
laissez-moi alex et moi voyez c'est la
première fois des vagues d'un mot
montclus rom taxes et les tarifs mais
laissez-moi expliquer les six mois
d'affilée en même temps et tous et
chacun son tour ces jeunes a fait les
six mois alors je voyais pas pouvoir
expliquer qu'on doit faire allusion de
l'expliquer et c'est bien la preuve et
je vais donc appartement qui est
conscient menaçant le voyons me laisser
m'explique j'en ai deux minutes pas
cette arriération et mais moi je m'en
fous de balancer ce que je voulais non
seulement je vous les donne pas mais je
répète et je m'explique je pars ya les
ratios mental pour cela parce que là
vous ne deviez faire nos adversaires
vous avez des regrets quand mais aucun
regret autres invités je parle de
tamisage fait insulter mais laissez-moi
m'expliquer a lésé ou totalitaire je dis
que j'ai la fia un mot monsieur a fait
une éruption volcanique et je peux pas
m'expliquer sur le rôle qu'annick genre
parler clairement que je dirai au gramme
de l'air je dis que c'est pas
démocratique d'insulter les gens je
parle de l'ariège h un arriéré mental
est ce qu on ira t-il à cet âge je perds
intérieur nous accepter ça dans votre
région d'arles d'arriération mentale
et si monsieur qui est un démocrate mais
laisse m'expliquer il va peut-être
peut-être vous expirez peut-être qu'on
est jeune et qui n'est pas insulter si
vous me laissez m'expliquer je peux
m'expliquer je j'ai le droit à deux
minutes à une minutes d'explications
pourquoi rire arriération mentale c'est
relier un mécanisme intellectuel c'est
pas relié à une personne
c'est un schéma intellectuelle qui est
complètement formulées dans tout le
discours des années 39 40 et qui est
débordés dépassés vous c'est c'est
démodé
je ne voulais pas vous en cause je mets
en cause de discours que vous tenez qui
frappe et d'arriération mentale je les
dis devant julien dray qui m'a donné
raison à raison on a typiquement là le
genre des changes selon lesquelles sur
lesquels surf le front national et
gilbert collard le fait admirable merci
vous vous promenez écoutez vous opposez
vous vous poser en victime du système
vous êtes là en essayant d'expliquer aux
français qu'eux ils ont tout essayé donc
finalement il ne reste que vous et voilà
tout votre programme
moi ce que je souhaiterais pour
effectivement contrer le front national
c'est qu'on parle de votre programme
économique parce que et je prends et
puis je prends ma part de responsabilité
et toute la classe politique devrait
prendre sa part de responsabilité
pendant trop longtemps on a été
effectivement dans le rejet pur et dur
sans même x x sayed expliqué de
décortiquer ce que propose le front
national résultat ils ont surfé
là-dessus et c'est grave
victime parce qu'aujourd'hui on entend
sur le terrain des gens qui disent je
vote front national on essaie d'engager
le dialogue avec audace et on essaie de
comprendre pourquoi mais on ne peut même
plus entrer dans le fond des choses on
ne peut plus entrer dans la questions
programmatiques
on est simplement comme la dans leur
rejet de la classe politique de son
système et gilbert collard joue
là-dessus admirablement si ce pan il
faut que les français comprennent bien
que derrière effectivement cette façade
il y a un programme économique qui
serait une catastrophe pour notre pays
et moi c'est de cela dont je voudrais
que nous débattions parce que c'est bien
beau de volants français yvan la sortie
de l'europe
la sortie de l'euro et le retour à la
retraite à 60 ans dites moi que vous ne
défendez pas cela mais bon moi j'ai eu
un autre programme on l'a même fait
chiffrer voyez-vous ici au groupe c'est
bien des républicains gagneraient en
amorçant même 4 milliards d'euros ne
sont pas souvent à vendre est le
couronnement puisse en débattre je
sortais un peu de vos coups sûrs parce
que vous nous accusez souvent d'être
dans la posture mais vous êtes tout seul
dans la posture où cette ruse est dans
la posture monsieur et vous éviter le
débat vous esquiver le débat
oui vous esquiver le débat parce que
vous êtes sûr de l'affichage et ce qui
est terrible pour nous et je le dis
c'est que nous avons le plus grand mal
effectivement à lutter contre cette
portion de cette posture la tête alors
je vous propose d'écouter la marion
maréchal-le pen vous êtes d'accord
vraiment sur la préférence nationale
c'est quand même unité du front
populaire
bon je tiens à dire quelque chose avec
vous le permettez je tiens à préciser
solennellement que j'ai pensé à quitter
cette émission si je ne la quitte pas
c'est par respect pour vous madame
tarnos et monsieur grossiord et pour
philippe dallier au plancher pour les
téléspectateurs pour les téléspectateurs
parce que je considère monsieur collard
que l'injure
mais vous n'avez rien de l'injure linge
ou n'avait rien compte n'est pas un
argument vous n'avez rien expliqué et le
fait qu'au bout de droit et que vous me
n'ai rien compris trois minutes des
relations prix vous pratiquiez l'injure
est rien c'est une manière de faire de
la politique
alors regardez et écoutez n'écoutez pas
la vision jugée et vous n'avez rien
compris je me suis expliquée clairement
alors il faut ajouter que julien dray
m'avait donné raison écoutez maintenant
fait que disait et nyerges marion
maréchal-le pen qui expliquait qu'une
page politique se tourne et on l'écouté
elle réagissait notamment à ce rang par
gilbert collard que certains donc et
tente de dresser dans trois régions de
france aujourd'hui le ridicule était la
mesure de la panique qui est la leur car
nous assistons définitivement j'en suis
convaincu à la fin du vieux monde de
leurs violons une politiciens
la première des valeurs de la république
bien c'était la démocratie la démocratie
dont il ne parle jamais d'ailleurs ça
nous intéresse pas pour la simple et
bonne raison qu'aujourd'hui la foule aux
pieds tout simplement ils sont
contraints au vu du retard d'additionner
leurs faiblesses
pour contrer la force de nos résultats
et bien je le dis il est scandaleux
scandaleux aujourd'hui de priver les
électeurs de la juste représentation qui
leur est dû alors jean pierre sueur le
retrait des listes sociale et c'est un
denim démographie mais pas du tout nous
considérons que ce parti est contraire
aux valeurs de la république
nous croyons aux valeurs de la
république et par conséquent nous
préférons qu'un républicain
même si c'est un républicain dont je ne
partage pas les idées même si c'est un
républicain que vous combattez c'est un
républicain
mais bon je ne combat pas mes collègues
qui sont dans d'autres groupes au sénat
je discute avec eux je m'oppose mais ce
ne sont pas des ennemis ce sont des
adversaires
soyons très clairs des adversaires
politiques mais nous avons en commun la
république et c'est pourquoi le parti
mais je ne crois pas ce n'est pas la fin
d'un système ce n'est pas la fin de la
république la république elle a connu
bien d'autres épreuves
et nous avons fait un choix difficile
très difficile vous savez moi je suis né
dans le pas de calais je le connais
beaucoup de monde dans le nord pas de
calais c'est un choix difficile et
douloureux mais parce qu'au dessus de
tout nous mettons le respect de la
république
est ce que vous comprenez leur fait de
votre ami jean pierre masseret de refusé
de retirer dans le rang mais beaucoup de
respect pour jean pierre masseret qui
est un homme très digne mais je je ne je
ne partage pas sa position qui manque d
inhiber cette position je dis que c'est
live
non mais manuel valls exprime moi je me
souhaite vous m'interrogez jeudi que
jean pierre masseret est un homme
respectable qui a qui s'est battu toute
sa vie pour ses idées il fait là un
choix que pour ma part je désapprouve
parce que je suis cohérent avec la
décision de mon parti qui est de tout
faire pour que nos régions soit dirigé
par un républicain y compris un
républicain qui ne partagent pas nos
idées politiques
on rêve il fait ce te ment tous au front
national il ne rêve que d'une chose
c'est de renverser la table
du passé faisons table rase et puis on
verra bien ce qu'il en sortira fait
dossier tandis sur le moi je pense que
le retrait des listes socialistes est
une erreur en matière de stratégie
politique
je pense que c'est une erreur parce que
vous rendez vous dimanche soir nous
verrons qui aura eu raison qui aura eu
tort
je pense que les électeurs d'abord ça
amène de l'eau au moulin du front
national quand ils disent c'est l'ump
ray c'est le système
ils sont tous pareils et ses îles surf
là-dessus également et donc c'est
apporter de l'eau à leur moulin
et par ailleurs je ne suis pas du tout
certain que dans l'électorat dans ces
différentes régions
on est le résultat que vous escomptez
donc moi j'aurais préféré effectivement
il ya le risque que le front national
sans par région mais ceci étant dit moi
je pense aussi à la suite à l'élection
présidentielle ferrée alors que les
listes socialistes se maintiennent et
que les électeurs fasse le choix qu'ils
ont à faire
voilà je ne veux pas donner
et que qui plaît tant au front national
qu'il y aurait d'un côté le parti
socialiste de l'autre côté les
républicains que tout ça c'est
exactement la même chose
d'abord 2002 c'était une élection
présidentielle on ne parle pas de la
même chose on ne parle pas la même chose
là on est sur des élections régionales
vous me permettrez de relativiser nous
sommes en plus dans un contexte très
particulier l'élection présidentielle en
2017 je le redis ça sera complètement
différent mais là je pense que le parti
socialiste fait une erreur de stratégie
politique
moi je suis consterné de voir quel point
le parti socialiste bafouent les lois de
la république et la démocratie canton je
peux vous êtes très aimable bien sûr que
la droite se retire et on a même le
droit de se coucher
je pense que quand on est élu on l'est
parce qu'on peut gagner mais aussi parce
qu'on peut perdre et les lecteurs qui
vous donne sa voix il vous la donne en
sachant que vous pouvez gagner comme
être dans l'opposition
c'est ce que nous avons toujours fait
démocratiquement c'est ce que je fais
démocratiquement à l'assemblée en
utilisant les armes juridiques de la vie
parlementaire qu'un grand parti comme le
parti socialiste certes aujourd'hui
effondré remaniement je ne verrais
dimanche l'effondrement renonce renonce
complètement à participer à la vie
démocratique en siégeant dans
l'opposition je trouve que c'est comme
le dit monsieur mennucci faire cocu deux
fois les électeurs
monsieur mennucci faire cocu deux fois
les électeurs pensent je pense qu'il ya
là un véritable déni de la vie
démocratique
un véritable mépris de la vie
républicaine qui à mon avis va peser sur
l'histoire du parti socialiste parce que
les électeurs seront toujours en droit
de dire mais pourquoi n'avez vous pas eu
le courage d'aller vous opposez dans les
hémicycles parlée par les armes
démocratique
oui au front national nous avaient
déserté ils vont apporter vos voix avait
là des hommes que violent que ce soit
des gens cachés a longuement vanté
plutôt qu'est-ce qui vais vous donner
oui mais voilà vous écoutez j'ai pas ses
idées on est opposée sur tout mais voilà
un homme que je respecte
oui parce que il est il est dans le
respect des lois républicaines
il n'est pas dans mon bureau politique a
fondé près de chez eux attendant qu'à
faire je crois que nous sommes très
nombreux à montrer ici et dans d'autres
lieux que nous ne craignons pas le débat
est d'ailleurs monsieur collard je ne
laisserai rien passer
j'espère bien tout à l'heure il
manquerait plus que ça tout à l'heure
vous avez ajouté une nouvelle imposture
oui bien sûr vous voyez vous vous avez
dit quand j'ai parlé de la préférence
nationale ni d'ailleurs le front
populaire gouvernement il y eut les font
plus rire oui alors le front populaire
revendiqué par le front national pour
défendre ses idées xénophobes
oui parce que c'est bien moi j'ai une
phobie et bien moi non mais moi je ne
dit pas n'importe où depuis deux mois ne
dit pas ce lâche n'ai pas dit c'est à
dire j'ai dit que le front national fait
dire au front populaire ce qu'il n'a
jamais dit ah bon et utilise vous
comprenez moi je suis monsieur aulas
toujours la préférence nationale je suis
pour la présidente nationale
je suis là et les préférences un élu du
département de janzé et de beaucoup
d'autres oui eh bien je n'accepte rai
voir le drapeau jaune accepte mais vous
acceptez ou de voûte je ne la connais
pas que vous utiliserez vous ne
l'acceptez plaire j'ai cela vous montre
que vous détournez l'asie noirs de
france - israël que je dis mais je me
porterai jeu que vous êtes toujours dans
l'impasse oui mais très heureux vide
votre étiquette vous dans le parti est
une imposture vivent ils ont aujourd'hui
bien avec ces accords contre nature
alors qu'il répondait aux mais c'est
notre invitées qui saluent un sacrifice
revendique non en tant que la
connaissance et vous écoutez je mets
tout
si on cède grand show de monsieur
couleurs on a l'habitude c'est
systématiquement j'ai dit pas c'est sa
cécité relatif c'est systématique
grasset systématiquement la même chose
beaucoup tenir m'adresser à vous écouter
vous me permettrez remplacer une quand
même passé je dis depuis le début de
cette émission aux cieux j'étais tout
seul deux autres mois peut-être je dis
monsieur vous allez le supporter que
depuis le début de cette émission vous
êtes dans notre grand show classe mais
si vous voulez on n'arrive pas à entrer
dans le détail les choses parce que à
partir du moment où on entrerait dans le
détail des choses on sait que vous soyez
gênée aux entournures c'est agresser
sans rien dire agressé excusez moi mais
par rapport aux propos que vous avez
tenus mais qu'est ce que j'ai dit je
soutiens que le parti socialiste est
atteint d'arriération mentale
il apparaît je sais pas si c'est tout à
l'heure vous des coûts de répondre est
acté oui c'est répondait sur l'a6 à la
préférence référence nationale
puisqu'elle est effectivement revendiqué
et assumé par exemple je posais jeu
philippe dellas préférence nationale est
l'un des credo du front national il ya
des textes il ya des lois dans ce pays
alors soit monsieur collard nous propose
de changer les lois à changer la
constitution changer les traités
européens
et puis nous expliqua après comment au
parlement à l'assemblée nationale est
ici au sénat on inscrit sa préférence
nationale qui propose aussi nommé là
aussi qu'est ce qu'on met derrière cette
hermelin s'il s'agit de savoir si
effectivement dans les régions dans les
communes on peut dans les achats faire
des circuits courts en privilégiant les
entreprises locales c'est de ça dont on
parle
excusez moi ça existe quasiment partout
s'est blessé face à laurent wauquiez par
exemple de cheval aux caissières
confiance il a dit dans tous les cas on
prend sa chance que l'on met
derrière les mots dans ce pays il ya des
citoyens français quelle que soit leur
couleur leur origine leur conviction
religieuse qu'ils en aient eu dans l'est
pas et il ya des étrangers qui sont en
situation régulière et qui ont des
droits je ne parle pas de ceux qui sont
en situation irrégulière ça c'est à la
une constatation un état de fait et
aujourd'hui la loi traite les uns ou les
autres dorment à deux manières
différentes en fonction des sujets mais
il ya des sujets sur lesquels il n'y a
pas de fonctionner le chocolat devrait
nous presser de logements attendant
perceur dernière et on avant c'était mon
tour très calmement
elle s'étend mais attend d eux vous êtes
quand même extrêmement bizarre
il serait temps en effet docteur à
l'argentin sert à l'ailé ce qui n'est
pas acceptable c'est la discrimination
ethnique pour l'attribution de logements
d'emplois qui figure nommément dans le
programme du front national d'autre part
il y a quelque chose de sacré voyez-vous
dans la république qui s'appelle le
droit d'asile pour les personnes qui
sont martyrisés oui on est tous d'accord
qui sont torturés et bien nous devons
les accueillir
qui dit contre et j'entends j'entends
des paroles selon lesquelles il faut
repousser qu'il faut fermer
regardez ce qui est 10 dans le nord de
la france qui a dit ça il faut fermer
il faut mettre les gens dehors et alors
ce qui dans votre dialectique d'étonnant
c'est que quand on vous dit ce que vous
dites vous dit comme ça mais qui a dit
sa personne mais non vous vous rendez
compte tout d'un coup que non vous ne
dites pas ça bah écoutez si vous ne
dites pas ça c'est très bizarre je ne
dis pas moi je n'emploierai pas des mots
comme vous avez employé je dirais que
vous utilisez des arguments qui sont de
base et a joué bien qu'ils sont
retrouvés oui de base étages et où sont
bien sûr évidemment viande reste de nos
valeurs de la république
et j'ajoute tellement de choses
tellement de choses par rapport au
respect dû aux religions quelles
qu'elles soient à leur proposer
à nos confères à doha la laïcité par
rapport à la laïcité que vous pouvoir en
parler on va en parler de l'accord et on
pas que j'ai compris j'ai compris vous
inquiétez pas je ne vais plus réagir
j'ai à faire
en quête d'idées rossi je vais le
prendre vite le sauveur a réagi les
dames en date en avant ce que veut dire
pourrons pour moi tous les citoyens d'où
qu'ils viennent
quelle que soit la couleur de leur peau
s'ils respectent la loi de la république
sont les bienvenus maintenant j'ai la
faiblesse oui je l'admets de bienvenue à
condition est de rio rit elle préférait
de préférer les arrose référé et d un
français que quelqu'un qui est un pays
où il peut aller parce que le français
il n'a qu'un seul pays c'est la france
oui ça vaut mieux lire tout et ça vous
l'oubliez voilà qui est dit alors on
aborde la deuxième question de
l'émission vous êtes tous d'accord sur
ce point j'espère maintenant comment
donc comment le front national at il
réussi à se hisser à ce niveau électoral
reste à responsabilité de la gauche qui
est au pouvoir ou de la droite qu'il a
été écoutée à ce sujet manuel valls et
nicolas sarkozy allait chaque fois que
la gauche a été au pouvoir s'est traduit
par une explosion du vote d'extrême
droite ensuite trois exemples 1986
monsieur mitterrand fait la
proportionnelle 35 députés du front
national de jean marie le pen à l'époque
qui rentre à l'assemblée nationale 2002
souvenez-vous cinq années de bionnay
jospin qu'est-ce qui se passe jean-marie
le pen une deuxième tour la gauche n'est
même pas au deuxième tour et là quatre
années de françois hollande
et c'est une exaspération qui montre
dans le pays
madame le pen était face à moi au
premier tour des présidentielles de 2012
à 18 % ce qui était déjà beaucoup ont
quatre ans elle passe plus de 27 % comme
vous l'avez dit mais j'entends moi bien
sûr est depuis longtemps la colère les
angoisses des français sur les questions
de sécurité sur le chômage sur
l'exclusion sur les peurs mais je ne
suis pas venu ici ce soir sur votre
plateau pour
m'excuser je souhaite rappeler quels
sont les enjeux de cette élection
régionale
il ya deux conceptions de la république
il ya deux conceptions de la france
celle de la république qui est exigeante
qui affirme l'autorité qui veut protéger
les français n'y qui veut aussi les
rassembler au nom de nos valeurs
et puis une vision qui est celle de
l'extrême droite étriqué petit et qui
n'offre aucune solution à ceux qui
souffrent et qui sont désespérés
philippe dallier on reprend avec vous
qu'il faut être important en temps de
parole je rends prendre la question de
cette deuxième partie comment en est on
arrivé là
si on écoute bien le premier ministre
l'économie sociale ne suffisent pas
probablement pas mais c'est une bonne
partie de l'explication
l'échec de ce gouvernement ou des deux
gouvernements successifs et un taux de
chômage qui atteint des records
c'est une grande partie de
l'exploitation après l'explication
le parti socialiste a perdu mais je
pense qu'ils doivent s'interroger sur
les raisons mais le parti socialiste a
perdu l'électorat populaire ça avait
même été théorisée par terra nova qui à
un moment disait bon bah écoutez les
couches populaires c'est perdu pour le
ps tournon nous plutôt vers les français
d'origine étrangère face tout cela
maintenant qui va falloir que vous
demandiez des comptes à ceux qui vous
ont soufflé ses idées brillantes
c'est tout ça mais l'électorat populaire
qui subit la crise de plein fouet
comment voulez-vous aujourd'hui qu'il ne
désespère pas ça c'est la vraie question
qui nous est posée est temps que dans ce
pays nous n'arriverons pas à faire les
réformes permettront de relancer la
machine économique et de redonner du
boulot à une majorité de gens nous nous
ressortirons pas et l'autre alors
nationale se refera là-dessus la paire
faire puis et puis vous rajouterez parce
que dans ces élections régionales il ya
les attentats du trésor qui
manifestement ont joué un rôle avec une
radicalisation d'une partie de
l'électorat qui a trouvé l'opportunité
avec ces élections d'exprimer aussi
sapeur jean-pierre serait ce que vous
reconnaissez que la politique suivie qui
est définie par le premier ministre
comme social réformiste mais qui
n'obtient pas pour l'instant le résultat
économique a pu jeter à jeter
effectivement une bonne partie de
l'opinion mocky la politique qui est
menée dans l'émoi de national difficile
et courageuse et je la défends bien
et nous l'amenons pourquoi ai je le dis
à philippe dallier parce que quand
nicolas sarkozy était président de la
république avec le gouvernement fillon
il n'a pas fait baisser le chômage il
n'a pas réduit les déficits
il a augmenté les impôts etc etc il n'a
pas réduit les charges des entreprises
il n'a pas réduit les dépenses publiques
mais il ya toute une série de choses
qu'il n'a pas fait
et nous nous avons dû prendre des
décisions très difficile et courageuse
et pourquoi je salue ce que fait
françois hollande manuel valls pour
aller dans le sens de la baisse des
charges de la compétitivité des entrées
non mais vous savez tout à fait raison
cela n'est pas suffisamment compris n'a
sans doute pas été suffisamment
expliquée mais c'est désormais jeudi les
résultats ne sont pas toujours au rendez
vous mais je dis que cette politique
économique et celle qui est aujourd'hui
nécessaire j'ajoute quelque chose c'est
que en effet dans le vote de dimanche
dernier
il y a eu incontestablement deux et deux
phénomènes
premièrement l'immigration et le
fantasme la peur de voir tous les gens
qui arrivent et tous ces gens qui
arrivent qui se voulait y fuit la mort 1
c'est un fait
et puis deuxièmement bien entendu ces
attentats et alors ces attentats c'est
terrible et moi je tiens à dire par
rapport à cela
voyez-vous ce que fait aujourd'hui
françois hollande moi je veux lui rendre
hommage parce que tant sur le plan
intérieur que sur le plan extérieur
il a pris toutes les décisions qui
devaient être prendre prise il a pris
toutes les décisions pour que la france
se défendent pour qu'elle lutte contre
le terrorisme
alors c'est la réalité et moi aucune
propagande ne m'empêchera de dire
chapeau à françois hollande et soutenons
le dans ce qu'il fait contre dèche et
contre le terrorisme en france françois
hollande a au moins un coup de chapeau
ça c'est bien c'est je revendiquerai
vous avez le droit
bon moi je voudrais faire plusieurs
observations si vous permettez
rapidement j'ai pas de raison funèbre de
qui que ce soit à faire en vantant les
louanges de qui que ce soit je voudrais
entrer dans ce qui me paraît essentiel
pour expliquer notre progression
nicolas sarkozy vous venez de le dire
remarquablement son quinquennat a été un
échec
merci de l'avoir dit ça m'avait fait
gagner du temps pour ce qui est du parti
socialiste géant écouter françois
hollande avec respect parce que je
respecte la fonction présidentielle
quand elle est en exercice évoqué les
mesures qu'il allait prendre les
citoyens ont dû faire comme moi il a
d'abord il a d'abord dit qu' il allait
mettre de l'ordre aux frontières et
qu'on allait exercer des contrôles
c'est ce qu'on dit depuis des mois et
des mois et des mois se faisant traiter
de xénophobe de raciste qu'on n'était
pas des républicains et puis il a dit
qu'on allait virer les imams radicaux
des mosquées si ce qu'on dise ça c'est
ce qu'on a dit c'est ce qu'ont adam
malysz a aidé et ça n'a pas une des
légendes unis appliquez vous déformez
après il a dit qu' on a vu que monsieur
valls lui même l'a dit qu'on ne pouvait
pas recevoir tous les migrants c'est ce
que nous disions depuis très longtemps à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai pris la
parole devant le chai 15,9 pour lui
demander s'il était certain que parmi
les migrants il n'y aurait pas des
terroristes dans le drame du bataclan l'
enquête de police anti terroriste révèle
que deux ou trois au moins des
terroristes était passé par la filière
des migrants bon alors on deux points la
syrie on disait il faut se rapprocher
c'est inévitable parce que pour aller au
sol
on a besoin de leurs troupes de bachar
el-assad on nous disait n'est pas
question au nom des valeurs
républicaines au nom de votre moral que
je respecte ce que vous êtes un homme
morale c'est bien je ne peux que le
respecter
aujourd'hui on se rend on se tourne vers
bachar el-assad poutine même chose
bon ce puits charest la troupe est où le
alors qu'est ce que vous répondez à cela
certains revirement récent de la
politique
les nouvelles jeunes et je n'ai plus
comme beaucoup que constater
effectivement que françois hollande
laurent fabius qui dirige la diplomatie
française a changé de position dans
notre camp il ya très longtemps que
françois fillon plaide effectivement
pour une autre approche qui règle ces
bruits vrai oui ça y est tout à fait
vrai le gouvernement s'y rend très bien
maintenant mais ils n'étaient pas suivis
par les maintenant monsieur me collard
m'essayer pas de faire croire aux
français non plus ne vous avez ou une
baguette magique et vous seriez capable
ou en été mais de prévenir tous les
attentats pensés que le ps que j'ai dit
ça mais écoutez en tous les cas où le
dimanche parce que j'ai dit tous les cas
moi je vous le dis donc neuf
effectivement le parti socialiste a
changé sa position de ce point de vue là
mais encore une fois je reviens aussi à
la crise économique parce que le terran
premier je pense que c'est la crise
économique l'incapacité de ce
gouvernement à inverser la courbe du
chômage
françois hollande a tellement promis au
moment de l'élection présidentielle de
et quand on promet on suscite de
l'espoir et quand après quasiment quatre
années on se montre incapable de tenir
les engagements qu'on avait pris comment
voulez vous ne pas désespérer
billancourt
comment voulez vous que les classes les
plus populaires qui votait
traditionnellement pour vous ne se soit
pas tourner vers d'autres
alors ils se sourient ne se tournent pas
non plus vers nous celle ci dans les
partis traditionnels
c'est une question traditionnelle c'est
une question de programme économique et
politique c'est la question est de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on réforme ce
pays
françois blanc le 31 décembre 2013 il a
changé le social libéralisme on nous a
inventé ça il a changé de politique mais
il est incapable d'aller au bout des
choses pour la bonne et simple raison
qui a pas de majorité à l'assemblée
nationale il sait ce qu'il faudrait
faire mais ne peut pas le faire et toute
la question c'est là effectivement
comment réformer ce pays
comment redonner de l'air à nos
entreprises comment redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux français
il a dessus les solutions du front
national alors là j'aimerais qu'on en
débatte parce que la corse est
le bc du mélange soit bien peur je ne
les jamais tous datant des jo c'est
parce que il ya deux débats en même
temps alors sur le débat économique
c'est vrai que françois hollande a
marqué une inflexion après quelques mois
après le rapport gallois et c'est un an
et demi non mais et cette orientation
moi je suis vous savez un rocardien et
je les suis depuis longtemps il fut un
temps même pas supporter 9,0 l'année
dernière les indiens oui tout à fait et
je pense que rocard avec tout sur
l'économie
et sinon je l'admets attend des
blessures qui font rimer comprennent non
mais simplement continuer à parler oui
lula cité rocard mais oui mais alors
c'est pas si c'est ça tu le vol
référence aux données alors ça fait donc
trois a toujours assumé la barre du
gouvernement je suis très très clair
premièrement puisqu'on a parlé de retard
il a dit qu'on ne pouvait pas assumer
toute la misère du monde il ya bien
longtemps mais que la france devait
prendre toute sa part oui mais lorsque
le front national oubli avant
deuxièmement entrèrent deuxièmement sur
le débat économique on a pris des
décisions difficiles il fallait les
prendre elle n'avait pas des prises à
voir je ne développe pas sur le
terrorisme
alors j'entends ce qui est dit il est
tout à fait clair que suite à des
attentats
où on à 140 de nos compatriotes qui sont
morts les autres blessés
le président de la république a réagi de
manière très ferme l'état d'urgence etc
ont la beauté et je moi je crois qu'il a
fait ce qu'il fallait faire à charmant
coulibaly notre côté il réaction
monsieur cola tout ce qui a été fait par
manuel valls et par bernard il a été
extraordinaire
d'autre part j'ajoute j'ajoute vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure des imams houllier
c'est le genre de simplification wii qui
fonctionne le
et c'est très intéressant votre discours
faut virer les imam radical mais attend
des imams radicaux vous le meilleur des
attend dé nous avons fait un rappeur à
porter vous vous rappelez je suis très
clair et précis il faut virer les imams
les imams briller radha kolhi radicaux
soyez pas souhaité ce qui ce qui est
très important c'est appliquer la loi de
la république la loi la loi mais
attendez la loi de la république elle
dit que lorsqu à nîmes à moineaux monier
ou quiconque que quiconque redevient de
produits d d d d exhortation à la
licence l'apologie du terrorisme qui
sont leurs assises et caetera et caetera
et bien la loi s'applique c'est une loi
pénale et toutes les conséquences
doivent en être tirées
wall mais sa lune mais c'est là le wac
deux de ses soldats en place mais
attendez il y a des qualifications
jeunes en omettant finale où il y en a
plus y en a beaucoup on a su qu'ils
n'ont cessé de nombreux imams pour qu'on
l'a pas fait avant sinon on n'est pas
dans un état de droit de décréter l'état
d'urgence pour un président de la
république quel qu'il soit ça n'est pas
une décision facile
bien évidemment qu'au soir du 13
novembre il fallait faire une président
de la république l'a fait est ce que si
après les attentats de charlie il
l'avait proposé demandé me collard mais
vous vous êtes omniscient non pas du
tout non tiens cette bourse ans
effectivement si le président de la
république en effet après les attentats
de charlie est ce que la population
française l'aurait acceptée aussi
facilement que cela je ne sais pas et
moi je ne jette pas et moi je ne jette
pas la meute elles abritent maintenant
qu'il faille avec la plus grande fermeté
utiliser tous les moyens de la loi
effectivement pour renvoyer chez eux
ceux qui sont ici et qui prêchent un
discours de haine celui dont il faut le
faire il faudrait certainement fallu le
faire avant parce que il faut bien se
rendre compte de l'impression que ça
laisse sur nos compatriotes
quand on voit le même de brest qui
explique à des gamins que s'ils écoutent
de la musique
qui seront transformés en cochons ça
lundi soir ne sont pas acceptables
et là dessus on aurait pu effectivement
aller plus vite et plus fort elle est
troisième question de se prépare trois
maintenant la consécration du front
national comme troisième force politique
donc à la hauteur des deux autres
annonces très sérieusement un mot un peu
lourd et si ce religieux attention non
on sait ce que en tous les cas donc le
nouveau paysage annonce pour demain mais
une vente et de recomposition politique
alors on va écouter jean pierre raffarin
qui voit la république lui en pleine
dérive c'est qui suppose selon l'ancien
premier ministre de changer de logiciel
politique on l'écoutait nous voyons bien
que la république est en train de
devenir impuissante impuissante au
tribunal impuissante à l'école
impuissante dans l'administration
impuissante pour l'emploi que la
démocratie n'a pas d'autorité donc je
crois qu'il faut qu'à un moment ou un
autre on accepte de se dire qu'on peut
pas invoquer nous les républicains tous
les jours la république la république si
elle n'est pas capable d'agir
donc je crois qu'il faudrait un jour se
mettent autour d'une table des
républicains convaincus dire comment on
donne du muscat la république au mans on
donne de l'ambition à la démocratie
comme on donne de l'autorité à notre
système politique et donc je crois qu'il
faut des réformes je crois qu'il faut
aujourd'hui apporter des réponses aux
citoyens mais courir derrière les
électeurs qu'ils soient du front
national ou du front de gauche ça ne
servira à rien alors quand vous entendez
ces propos est-ce que vous vous dis
qu'effectivement demain il pourrait y
avoir je sois une recomposition
politique une coalition des républicains
de droite d'euros c'était la fois le
rêve de marine le pen est peut-être
c'est peut-être plus embêtant le rêve du
président de la république actuel
annoncé certainement pas mon rêve à moi
et pour revenir à ce que je disais au
début de l'émission voilà pourquoi je
pense que la stratégie du retrait des
listes du ps est certainement une
mauvaise chose
voilà il ne pense qu'à une chose faire
croire aux français que tous les autres
sont les mêmes et qu'ils développent les
mêmes politiques ce qui est ennuyeux
aujourd'hui c'est que l'échec du
gouvernement actuel est tel que ça à
crédit de 70 hinault et donc la
recomposition
politique derrière voit bien que
certains après j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour jean pierre raffarin mais là je ne
partage pas son analyse
oui le franc il a raison quand il dit
que la république est en dérive
en tous les cas que ce pays je vais dire
ce pays et pas seulement les politiques
pas seulement ceux qui gouvernent
il ya aussi les français en face il faut
aussi que les français comprennent qu'il
va falloir réformer ce pays et que
réformer le pays pour le relancer
ça sera difficile et douloureux et qu'il
va falloir accepter un certain nombre
d'efforts ils ont peut-être trop souvent
ça va moi j'avais l'habitude de dire et
je vois que jean christophe fromantin a
repris là à la même formule en dix ans
les français aussi la classe politique
qu'il mérite a toujours voté pour ceux
qui crient plus fort ou pour ceux qui
promettent la lune alors même que l'on
sait que la lune est difficile à
décrocher
ça conduit parfois des situations
composer les réformes seront difficiles
et douloureux au les derbys ont porté et
comment mais pour qui il va falloir que
ce soit pour tout le monde et qu'on
répartisse effectivement la charge mais
il va avec ma maman il va falloir
réduire le poids de la dépense publique
dans ce pays pour réduire les impôts
réduire le poids la dépense publique ça
va être faire des économies dans les
services publics
et ça va être extrêmement compliqué mais
si on ne le dit pas aux français au
moment des campagnes électorales comment
voulez vous le leur faire accepter après
on a parfois fait cette erreur dans le
passé le parti socialiste
ils ont été dramatiques de ce point de
vue là en 2012 donc moi je voudrais que
l'on parle de ces sujets là parce que
tout le reste savez c'est très facile de
promettre la lune pour demain
aujourd'hui c'est ce que fait le front
national les français nous ont vus à
l'oeuvre ils ont tendance à dire ben
écoutez vous avez échoué on va essayer
autre chose il faut penser aussi à la
suite vers collard est ce que le front
national est capable de tenir ce langage
de la lune pour revenir vers vous je
pense d'abord qu'on est la première
force politique du pays
ensuite tout à l'heure quelque chose a
été dit qui y est significatif du
comportement politique
vous avez dit à propos de l'état
d'urgence quand j'évoquais coulibaly
charlie vous avez dit j'ai noté la
population ne l'aurait pas accepté pas
forcément j'ai bien joué il ya deux
choses
le devoir d'un homme d'état et tout est
là est la différence entre nous elle est
là on vous écoute c je peux pas vous si
c'était pas bien écouté vous nous avez
vous nous interrompre essence un
allègement également réagi ça vaut y
aller j'y allais je vous en prie allez y
vous écoute et vous lirez agir non je
les fais abanda compétents métallier
nous dire que les hommes de ce côté là